thank you very much for inviting me hard
clips to follow okay I'm going to kick
off by first of all saying that we went
to the London Games I'm gonna introduce
you to my world of elite sports we're
going back to the velodrome and what
happened there
fantastic privilege to be part of the
team that supports easily found
elites and you probably want to know
what I actually did so I'm going to try
and run through about 30 years of
experience and knowledge in about 10
minutes
so we're off I'm a psychiatrist I'm a
doctor specializing in looking after the
human mind and basically my aim from my
perspectives to make you happy confident
and successful people and that's a tough
challenge and there's a good reason okay
imagine you offered a machine okay so
you're just thinking he's this machine
I'm going to offer you now and it's made
you really happy it can give you
confidence success it stops you from
ever being anxious or worrying and
removes all unpleasant thoughts and
feelings okay you'd say I assumed please
give me the machine the really good news
is this start smiling because you've
already got the machine alright let the
penny drop the machine is with you okay
it's called your mind and some of you
don't know what's going on in fact
probably all of you don't know what's
going on so I'm going to illuminate you
today by saying look this is what's
going on in your head and there's a
little bit of a surprise with it why
isn't my mind doing these things if you
say if it's such a good machine why is
it not functioning and we've got a
little bit of a puzzle here let's
imagine a Martian came down and had to
look at this hole it said there's lots
of these human creatures about and they
don't make sense to me and this is the
puzzle while you're sitting there calmly
you're in charge of your legs you don't
sit and get someone jump up run around
the auditorium and shout sorry I had a
leg attack okay that doesn't happen and
yet you sit there with your mind going
all over the place giving you thoughts
and feelings that you don't particularly
want and there doesn't appear to be any
control so that doesn't make sense to me
as a doctor as a scientist I'm thinking
why do you not have the control over
something that's in your head so it's a
bit of a puzzle so let me solve the
puzzle you're not alone okay you're not
alone
there are two of you in your head okay
so let me show you what's going on
because someone else is sharing your
life and has the power let's investigate
it so we're going to start with a tough
bit so I hope you drank your coffee this
morning
the breathing conflict now if you're one
of the medical students at Sheffield
University
I'm undergraduate Dean I might test you
on the end of this but I'll let you get
away with it so these are the fancy
names behind me you don't need to
remember them but let's have a look at
the brain your brain in conflict okay so
what you've got is not actually one
brain but a series of brains that in the
womb all start growing as little units
and then link in and lock into a brain
and cause you to have a lot of problems
because when these units get together
they don't always agree on what's going
to happen and the problem you've got
with the human brain is this you've got
all of these components and if you look
at that brain on the screen the part
which is in the dark yellow up front the
biggest bit is your thinking brain only
the edge thinks only the cortex things
so the rest of its just a machine and
the middle bit surrounded by the
cingulate gyrus and underneath is called
the limbic system and it reacts it
doesn't think it just reacts now if that
were your brain you wouldn't have a
problem you'd have a reacting bit that
tells you the instincts and drives what
to do and then a thinking bit which is
you saying well I'll make a choice now
we have a major problem the brain didn't
steer like that the little bit in the
middle which is an automatic emotional
machine decided to push its way out to
the edge of your brain and it grabbed
part of the cortex and said I want to
think too so now you've got this little
machine in your head that's starting to
think for you but it doesn't think the
same way as you you think rationally and
logically this little bit of brain
thinks emotionally and catastrophically
so let's see it in action all right you
come into college you come into school
one day and you hear someone say by the
way do you know Saunders just said
you're really quite dense you really
shouldn't be in this College there's
something wrong with it all right so you
think okay here goes the brain reacting
number one brain immediate shout Keller
alright number two is the time hang on
don't kill
don't kill her we have to do it socially
aware so let's do it deviously all right
number three is your conscience and
guilt that says hang on it's in between
the two it's got an impossible job to
keep them apart and stop them acting and
it doesn't do very well it's not as
strong in most of us it gets persuaded
by the other two maybe maybe it's not so
bad all right number four says I'm not
interested in motion I just want you to
give me the facts and the evidence and
I'll just do calm and logical and
collected number five says I don't know
why it's all about me me me how about
the other person let's think of empathy
and compassion why would this person say
this about me I've got to understand
them and number six is well I'll just
tap into how bad this actually is and
then look at the memory banks and say
what happens if you go and kill someone
and ones if you talk to them and what
happens so these six brains are now
fighting each other and one of them has
got to get control I'm hoping that the
laughter when I said number one kill
them doesn't mean that's the usual one
that gets control you have now this
massive conflict it's too complicated so
if I start working for you to see it as
an elite athlete what's going on in your
head is you got on that bike in the
velodrome there's too many brains trying
to speak can we make it simple the
answer is yes if you look at the
neuroscience of the brain it actually
boils down to three teams and three
teams are in your head and they're all
fighting as a team to get control of
your actions your feelings your thoughts
so let's discover what the new rasayan
says about this oK we've got a machine
without our permission grabbing hold of
you giving you emotions and thoughts you
really don't want anxiety worries
concerned trying to please everybody
else worried about what everybody thinks
about you and you deep down of thinking
I want to do this I keep doing it okay
so let me introduce you to that machine
this is your inner chimp you need to say
hello to them
they've been with you since you were
born in fact they were there before you
you're the intruder and they're running
your life and you're interfering you're
interfering so you need to get to know
this machine really well if you're going
to be successful
simplified brain therefore if we look
again is this you live in your frontal
lobe that's the main area that you
dominate
you think very clearly your inner chimp
lives in the limbic system and thinks
very catastrophic ly and emotionally and
finally the rest of it can be put
together and we're stick it up for
convenience in the parietal lobe and
that's just a computer running the
system and it's seem to the chimp and
human I'm here at your availability what
do you want to do with me so now we
understand these are the three
components going on in your head okay
the problem with the computers the chimp
put lots of rubbish in so there's lots
of gremlins in there with silly believes
and silly actions to promote its
behavior so the stacked really heavily
against you actually succeeding okay so
what we've got a three thinking brains
in your head you've got you facts truths
and logic you got the chimp feelings
impressions emotions and a computer
which is a machine tune use me as you
wish and the chimp usually uses it first
so you have a choice human a chimp how
do you know who's in charge it's dead
easy all you gotta says do I want do I
want these feelings no it's the chimp do
I want these thoughts no it's the chimp
and you'll probably find 90% of your day
the chimps in charge okay it's it's time
to change it round first you've got to
recognize who's thinking which part of
your brain has got the blood supply and
using the oxygen up because that's got
the power
can we actually shift it by boxing the
chimp with truth and fact and then
finally choosing the thoughts you want
the answer is yes you can but it is a
skill why is it so difficult the chimp
brain is five times stronger than you so
you're gonna have to be pretty clever
okay he or she wins they know what to do
with you you have to learn about your
chin and be ready for it so let's show
you an example you go into a room for a
meeting and you're first in the room and
the people before left to play two
biscuits as a chocolate biscuit and
three plain biscuits so that's the
message coming into the thalamus in your
brain and it sends a message you leave
it to the chimp you have no choice on
that the chimp gets first bite and the
chip immediately grabs the chocolate
biscuit before anybody comes in and eats
it quick okay and then it looks into the
sari annihilates you as a human just in
case you try and stop it it hit you with
a brick it uses up to 30
neurotransmitters to make sure you don't
interfere with this action all right so
that's the way the brain works don't
blame me
hyah all right so you look into the
computer and then a little gremlin says
eat the rest of them you'll never get
caught all right so you scoff all of
them you think you've got away with it
and everybody else comes in Roman czm to
play it unfortunately you then belch and
everyone says that smells like chocolate
biscuit and so now you as a human get
the message in apologize profusely all
right that's the way it works
your chimp acts first you then calm down
and then you apologize if you recognize
the pattern we need to do something
about it you can there's the missing our
I'll put in you can actually go straight
to the computer and stop the chimp in
its tracks so if you look in that
computer remove the gremlins and put
some autopilots these are constructive
helpful beliefs values you hold such as
it isn't important what everybody thinks
about me it is important to please
everyone it is important to hold my
morals then when the chimp goes to do
anything it looks in the computer and
stops so the computer eventually holds
the power so this is quite a complicated
system but if you get it right it means
you can succeed in life
so let's look what happens with elite
athletes there they are getting on the
bike Chris Hoy and his chimp Victoria
pendel and her chimp get on the bike and
they have very different thoughts
the chimps thought will be I've got to
win a gold medal it's very important I'm
muscle everyone down the crowd looks big
and angry what if my rivals look bigger
than me I can't fail I don't want to be
here this is the chimp rattling away
doing what's natural and healthy the
human however has got the choice now
so both Chris and Vicky and experts in
this they've got the skill and they just
box the chimp and see right what do I
want to think on the think of process
I'm going to go and enjoy myself and do
my best because that's all you can ever
do in life do your best and enjoy it the
same for you on the day of an
examination
I teach medicine at Shepherd University
and students have to go to rigorous
exams and of course you can imagine
there you are walking into your exam
with your chimp and it's Wittering away
to you I wish I'd revised more now why
do they keep watching television was it
so important to see strictly well
probably from Vicky's point of view but
your chimp is rattling away our students
do you don't have to
it up with this you can actually start
managing yourself you can actually live
in a skill that puts the chimp in a box
you are responsible you can't then say
I'm sorry sir I didn't do well in the
exam it was my chimp it made me watch
the telly
alright that's no loud okay laughs like
I've been the dog that bites someone you
say well I didn't bite it was the dog
you know you're responsible you are
responsible for your chimp so don't
blame it okay remember you always have a
choice you can choose to go through life
listening to your chimp or you can
become human and manage your chimp it's
a skill to manage you're in the chimp so
you have to practice until you get it
right it's not easy okay so when Chris
and Vicky got on the bikes it wasn't
easy pulling all that hard work into the
gym hard work on the track it was really
going against nature and said I'm not
gonna go natural I'm going to go
unnatural and that's why I'm asking you
to do in your minds I'm saying stop
going natural because it's very
destructive to you we're really built to
live in a jungle not society I'm going
to say go unnatural turn your mind off
and start being the calm collected human
that you really are and stop being
fooled and hijacked by your inner chimp
your chimp isn't bad or good it's a
chimp so don't start saying what Vicky
Pendelton one asked me how do i murder
the chimp all right you can't do that
you have to look after it
the secret is system talk to your chimp
reason with it
help it okay take care of it and then it
won't cause you any problem but if you
don't look after it and you not even
aware it's there you're in serious
trouble
you have to reassure your chimp and look
after it okay this was a rattle through
of what can be hopefully for some of
your life change when you start to
realize this fantastic machine in your
head is there for your use all you got
to do is start understanding it and then
get a skill to operate with it and get
to be the person you really want to be
thank you for listening I wish you and
your chimp every happiness and success
in life
you